un peu plus sur le
terrain, n'attendez pas que l'ombre en sorte, ce sera un
zoom avant, c'est la photo
ici pour le sol, la rive proche arrive
un
peu par-dessus et maintenant nous allons St s'il vous plaît  ouais,
continuez, je veux dire, le tir wi-fi va couper avec style
avec le CL d'eux tirant le poisson
ouais, ok, coupez s'il vous plaît
[Rires]
ne continuez pas,
beaucoup d'oiseaux passent
là-bas et continuent de voler tout droit
[Rires]
[Musique]
devant la
tête
[Musique]
coupe
sympa
ouais oh il y en a plein euh regarde
ça regarde ce qui est devant toi ok eh
bien je pense que je pense que nous avons nous avons de
belles photos des pêcheurs là-bas
ouais au moins c'est du ping dans certains poissons
qui  c'était
bien c'était à gauche
[Musique]
ok eh bien je pense qu'on devrait peut-être
aller plus haut maintenant oui ok oui fais ça
regarde h
Bonjour rouler ok oui rouler on peut
monter haut tirer au maximum tirer
haut c'est ce que je  je lui ai déjà dit que tu
sais qu'il faut aller de plus en plus haut, nous grimpons, nous
pouvons grimper beaucoup plus pour un taux de montée maximum,
peux-tu s'il te plaît répéter si nous pouvions
grimper beaucoup
plus vite ouais ouais c'est tout, nous
allons arrêter oui, ce que je pense que nous devrions
faire, c'est obtenir  un peu plus loin
et et depuis la
mer c'est
bien euh eh bien je pense qu'on aurait dû aller
un peu
plus loin non d'accord
non l'angle n'est pas bon hein ouais d'accord
on se retourne et on continue un autre enregistrement vas-y
pour
le
e
hé
[Musique]
en bas
arrête le
euh vers le
mur le mur le le le barrage le
béton oh oui d'accord juste le